ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show
i am tim dillon comedian member of the
media
and the father of candace owens child
and i did not announce that when she was
on but i feel like it's time to come
clean with you and let you know that the
child of candace owns will be having
is mine
[Music]
ben by the way a lot of people not
really
four were angry about candace
coming on the show and they said i
didn't push
back enough which i did but you know who
did
no pushback ben
ben said nothing the entire interview
he wasn't even on screen okay
and i don't platform anyone he runs the
tech
he chose to platform candace owens
and say nothing not one rebuttal
i thought he booked megan the stallion
i was shocked that candace owens was on
the show i apologize
it was very tough to hear for many
people
my aunt who is a liberal heard the
episode
and you know what she did what shot
herself
she shot herself in the face
after she heard the episode
and i feel so what was that thing on the
legion of skank subreddit
you read about my stepmother oh
supposedly it's like folklore on that
subreddit that someone showed up to your
stepmother's house and said hi i'm a fan
of tim dillon
and she got really mad and and what do
they get for that clout
i think that's clout yeah hey if you
want that's cloud
saying i'm a fan of timmy if you want
clout kill her
you want real clout kill her
i'm kidding it's the holidays it's the
holidays
in l.a and the decorations are out and
you can't see them and if you try to see
them you'll be in jail
i don't know why we've even put the
decorations up this year
let's skip it let's skip it
if you drive down sunset boulevard or
west hollywood there are actually
decorations and no people
it is such a haunting scene
and then there's all these lines of
covet tests everybody's getting tested
for covin
in the car it looks like in and out but
everybody's getting a q-tip up the nose
to see if they have sars cove to
the coronavirus what a shitty way to
spend a day
you know man
i was watching that comedy store uh
documentary
the other day and uh on showtime
and uh there are parts of it that are
well done and then there are parts of it
where you go
huh i re so they the episode i watched
last night they get whitney rogan burr
leno annie letterman and they all
take covet tests they all have masks on
and they have
they take covet tests and then they sit
down and mike binder who did the
documentary by the way it's like about
him
think about him what's going on
he's like it's mostly about my journey
with splashes of kenneth in here and
there
little prior but more me
they're all sitting outside and i and
i'm not bitter that i'm not in it i've
seen it now now i'm like
kind of like that i'm not in it but i
got passed at the comp don't be nervous
i got passive to comedy i don't care if
i ever do this again for living
i truly don't i truly truly don't uh i
truly don't
i um i was passed at the comedy store
about um which i love i love the store
uh i was passed like a few weeks after
this happened
you know after the whole thing was shot
with the majority of it but they shot a
scene where everybody gets coveted
and so apparently it's in the midst of a
pandemic
and then mike binder looks at everybody
and goes what's going on with pc
culture
and i'm like what in the [ __ ] are you
talking about
the biggest event a seismic
event an asteroid that hit
live performance harder than anything
this guy's going
what do you think about pc culture and
then there's comedians
by the way everyone in that documentary
is like 75.
i got to be honest i got to be honest
you start looking around you're going i
don't know does it feel that
hot stand up don't feel that hot
right now it's like it's all like
elderly people telling you
well when i was a youth richard
it's like it's not it and i love
stand-up and i love doing it and i'll
keep doing it
but part of the reason why i like it is
it is a dead art
okay and and and that documentary
i mean christ
it's just it's a museum it's a mausoleum
in there i mean some mausoleum
i mean i was watching with a friend
who's a fan of everybody and they're
like
here's the question i love comedy and
comics are more talented
inherently than tick-tock people but is
a documentary about the tick-tock kids
more interesting
yes is and i like that you didn't
hesitate
it's a documentary about the kids on
tick-tock more interesting
than somebody being like it's just a
joke
[Laughter]
no one cares about pc look guys it's not
even real
i had candace on nobody's people were
mad at me but nobody's trying to cancel
me it doesn't it's over
no one cares and it's still like this
narrative that people keep bringing up
it makes stand-ups look
weak you look weak when you
whine just say it and step
back when i was fighting with people on
twitter
about the candace owens thing i was
fighting because i had a point
i had a point and they had a point they
whatever their point was whatever my
point was
but i don't care that you're mad i knew
you were gonna be mad when we had her on
the show
that's part of the fun
you see i'm not bringing on a history
teacher
who no one knows or cares about i'm
bringing on a woman who's gonna ruffle a
few feathers
i get so this whining week piece it's
just
got it's every podcast has been about
this
and only this
so i watched that for a few minutes and
then i had to turn that off
it's just a joke you got jay leno up
there be like
it's a duck what are we doing
what's going on here who cares i don't
care
enough with the legends enough with the
don't you want to kill these people
do these people die do they ever go away
having these [ __ ] have not been
funny in forever
forever and we all have to sit there
like they're [ __ ] christ they climb
down off the cross and we got to wash
their feet
and annoy it's enough is enough already
and i respect them
and uh you know i respect i respect the
the roads they paved so that i may have
to drive
down them but we got to be funny here
doesn't everyone remember that we got to
be a little
funny we can't just sit around on
a trillion dollars they should make
chairs made of money
when they ask these people to pay they
should have to sit in a chair of money
they have to take the money out of their
banking and make a couch of it
and we're making money we're not
[ __ ] on people that make money
but it's like it's a pandemic there's
all this [ __ ] to talk about nobody cares
about pc culture
nobody gives a [ __ ] enough pipe down
go down to comedy magic club tell
everybody you know tell everybody that
the pc culture can you can wade through
an anti-mask protest on the way in there
down in hermosa beach
the l.a lockdown's confusing because
you're not supposed to leave your house
but the mcrib is back
it's odd it's a strange thing go down
and let's see what we can do and what we
can't do because i don't even know
non-essential travel of any kind is is
is is
banned that word essential
is a very subjective word closure of all
on-site restaurants though takeout
delivery remains open
personal services hair salons
barbershops are closed
essential retail open
okay parks and beaches remain open for
activities but no gatherings go alone
schools following protocols can remain
open if they have a state
waiver
people are like the lockdown's not going
to do enough it's not severe enough
what do you want the tanks in the street
so there are several exemptions
faith-based outdoor services and the
homeless
i don't even know what that means by the
way this is not the new studio the new
studio is being built
yes it's going to be very exciting
you're going to love it it's going to be
great
this made me laugh the other day get
this up josh richards who's a tick-tock
kid
we like because he's industrious is
handing out blankets to the homeless
and i think he's an investor in the
blanket company
where he's handing out blankets
to the homeless and that's kind of funny
can we can we play this i mean i don't
think we can can we
without volume i think we can because
there's probably music in this
let me see
see we have a plan everyone says l.a
doesn't have a plan it's right here
what's the i think kevin newsom is doing
a great job what's the prize to plan
right here
the tick tock kids are giving blankets
to the homeless people is
is that not a plan i think it's great
now go find out if he owns i think he
owns a part of the blanket company
i think he said on his twitter which is
great because as you're giving the
blankets to the homeless you're kind of
also selling them
and going hey if you scratch a few
dollars together
you might want to think about purchasing
one of these
you might want to think about you might
want to think about getting involved
but this seems like a great plan
remember when i joked around this is why
i should never joke
because everything i say comes true
remember when i said this was months ago
that if you were [ __ ] during this
economy you couldn't rely on the
government you had to hope that david
dobrik shot you with a potato gun
or that jeffree star decided to put 5
in your account on venmo remember when i
said that you were only going to be
relying on
influencers i said that and i said it is
a bit
it is now a reality if you are homeless
in los angeles hopefully your needs
dovetail with an influencers publicity
campaign
hopefully you get chosen to be one of
the people
handed out a product that's all you got
now
good luck good luck getting anybody else
interested
these guys are walking around handing
out he goes like this
this is like the funniest i mean i just
folks gotta laugh
and this kid like i don't hate the kid
at all but i would do [ __ ] like like if
i was him
i i'm not gonna be him but if i was him
i would do [ __ ] like this
he's like he goes i am pleased to
announce that i am joining unhide
whatever that means as co-creative
director as an investor and a partner in
the company i believe will change the
world
i hope through my actions i can expire
generation z to take on the issue of
animal efficacy
right and join me in my mission to
create a national conversation about it
so what is that the blanket company yeah
i believe so uh what is the blanket
company
so i think they don't use animal fur
like they don't so it's awesome well
that's what the homeless are concerned
about
here's a blanket and there were no
animals made the homeless were like can
you get some animals and cook them and
bring them to me
oh folks folks it doesn't get better
than this huh
this is ellen degeneres's faux fur brand
so you know what it is
it is not made out of animal products
it's made from the hair of her
interns which she plucks out one by one
when they're late
so ellen degeneres who's as we've
covered runs in
abu ghraib style torture prison at her
show is now making blankets
out of her interns body hair which are
being handed out to homeless people
by josh richards and the tick tock kids
that's what i'm hearing
and i'm for it i'm not against any part
of it
every mechanism there i think is working
the way it should work
if i was homeless and i saw two kids in
beanies cool little young kids come up
to me
i gave me a blanket and they said by the
way this is uh no animals used and uh
hey here's a gift from ellen i'd say
thank you
and here's a gift from ellen
so that's what that's that's the la
homelessness
thing here don't worry about it
i i i i hope everybody is is
as excited about this as i am in this
city this
rapidly crumbling metropolis magic speed
on my spoon
magic spoon on my spoon
i'm delirious magic spoon on my spoon
magic spoon is a cereal will you pay
attention
magic spoon is a cereal for people that
want to be healthy
it's got the magic spot on my spoon
magic spoon on my spoon
it has zero
it has zero grams of sugar 11 grams of
protein
and three net grams of carbs in each
serving so many of you have asked you
can build your own custom variety box
you could choose from the best-selling
cocoa fruity frosted and blueberry
flavors plus
brand new flavors including peanut
butter and cinnamon spin on my spoon
magic spoon on my spoon
it tastes amazing it's keto friendly
gluten free
grain free soy free low carb and gmo
free
i like the fruity flavor it tastes like
froot loops magic
spoon on my spoon if they use that as a
jingle i'll soothe them you hear that
magic spoon on my spoon
there's just something nice about that
go to magicspoon.com tim dillon to build
your own custom variety box and try
today and be sure to use promo code tim
dillon to check out to get free shipping
magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's back with a 100 happiness
guarantee if you don't like it for any
reason they'll refund your money
no questions asked that's magicspoon.com
tim dillon and use code tim dillon for
free shipping it's
yummy raycon
earbuds are here
raycon raycon
raycon is being generous for the
holidays
raycon they're earbuds like uh apple but
better and cheaper
you know i mean that's what they are
that's what that's what's going on out
there
the audio quality is amazing it's
comparable to what you get from other
premium
brands except raycon started half the
price
best of all this is something they can
use for calls or music
work or play at home or on the go it's
the gift that keeps on giving
if you already have a pair of wireless
earbuds you always need to spare
okay is that okay with you
seamless bluetooth pairing and a
comfortable noise isolating fit
you can start listening right out of the
box and keep listening for hours
there's so much play time
raycon's being generous for the holidays
so on top of their everyday grade prices
they're offering my listeners 15 off
right now
isn't that nice go to buy recon dot com
slash tim today to get 15
off your raycon order that's by raycon
r-a-y-c-o-n
by raycon.com tim byraycon.com
tim so important
so i watched this show on netflix the
other day nate uh
it's a one-woman show by natalie
palmedius who's a very talented comedian
i i don't i didn't go through the whole
show so i don't want to comment on the
show
some people will love it some people
won't it's it's it's a one
woman show um
she's she's uh dressed up there as her
character nate
and the whole show is about consent this
is the
this is what i was confused there's like
a scene where she's got a mannequin on
the floor
yeah and she's it's about toxic
masculinity the whole show
by the way every man i know every
straight man i know is like weeping
openly
where is this toxic masculinity i'd like
to see more of it you know who has a lot
of toxic masculinity recently
women they're tough as nails
but men are like openly weeping every
straight friend i have cries all the
time
yes it's because i'm always telling them
how horrible they are and everything
but who's gonna do that if not me
so this nate is about toxic masculinity
about men running around and being toxic
and just
raping and pillaging essentially and
there's like uh there's a scene where
there's a mannequin on the floor
and nate the character goes i don't know
what to do what should i do with the
mannequin on the floor
who is looking at someone
i know that there are rapists and i know
that there's frat boy douchebag
i'm not the guy that doesn't believe any
of that
but who is looking at someone on the
floor
and going there's a gray area here
i don't understand i watched someone
have a heart attack once in a diner i
got up and left
i said goodbye i was out
who was looking at someone on the floor
i didn't go to a four-year college
and i know things go on there people
drink whatever
but it seems like you know it's like oh
there's a lot of gray area out there
there is but there's also not
right there's a lot of black and white
areas of like don't rape
people
there's a point in the show that's a
little culty where she's like
ask ask and the audience is like ask
ask
i'm just confused clearly a talented
woman i'm just confused about
the issue here of consent i'm i'm
confused
about it apparently there's much more of
a gray area than i had
originally imagined i thought
that if someone is too drunk to have sex
with you do not
have sex with them
if someone is passed out on the floor
certainly
do not have sex with them give them a
blanket
give them a blanket that ellen degeneres
made but don't have
sex with them so i'm just confused but
again people are gonna get mad at me
they're gonna be like you don't
understand the rape that goes on
everyone is raped at every minute of
their lives
you fat [ __ ] just cause you don't get
raped
doesn't mean i'm sorry i've never been
you got to apologize to people now that
you you haven't been raped and that
you're not dead of covert
every day you should be dead the choices
you've made in your life
i'm sorry i'm not dead of covert and i'm
sorry i haven't been raped i hope they
happen at the same time
so you can all have an i told yourself
festival somewhere
you have to apologize for just being
alive
and it's just such a nice way to call
you a fat [ __ ] with people going
you better watch out about this people
call you they go
you got to be careful you have to be
real
you have to be careful you have to be
very careful
you look at you if people are calling
you
and telling you to be careful you look
like [ __ ]
that's just the reality if people are
really calling you concerned about
calvin
you look like [ __ ] that's just a great
way to know and just know it
just be aware i've had fat friends i was
talking to ray this morning
i've had fat friends that had no idea
they were fat there was a girl in the in
the store
the other day and they're like she's
walking around lashing the polo out like
she's loud
she's like getting everyone to help her
and find things
if you're a fat person in a clothing
store you should treat it like a heroin
attitude just got out of prison
keep your head down walk around quietly
and get out of there
go in try a few things on quietly and
then go oh none of them fit and then
leave
and then go sit your corny chick-fil-a
don't be like
the queen of the store be like get me
[ __ ]
all right that's a dot
so when someone calls her up because you
got to watch out for covet she goes what
do you mean
but that's a great way if you don't know
how you look
how concerned have people been about you
getting covered
if people call you up and they're like i
don't think you should leave your house
even to take hey even to take a walk put
that mask on
even to take a walk put that mask on
because you know you have to be very
careful
you have to be very good it's just
another way of telling someone
we are shocked you're not dead already
we are so surprised you're not dead
every time you post on social media we
imagine that it's a memorial page it's
an in memoriam
we can't imagine it's actually you we
can't imagine there's a disease out
there
that hasn't killed you
that's how people are acting right now
how's your family in texas we're doing
with coveted has anyone had it does
anyone you know have it
not yet well my uncle had it actually i
forgot how did he do
he's okay he's powering through just a
mild case he got it at the school
where he coaches you know i think i had
it in march i had
you know and i know everybody says this
this is a constant refrain
but in march i was sicker than i had
ever been
right yeah for like four weeks i was so
sick i was coughing
i had a fever i was like waking up in
the middle of the night shivers
the whole thing and uh and then i
you know took me three or four weeks to
get my strength back
and to feel that i was
back it kicked my ass so i am convinced
that that was
something maybe covet
i know a young healthy dude who's now
gotten it twice
oh really yeah so i'm wondering if if
the antibody tests are wrong or
like maybe he never had it the first
time maybe there was a false positive
or you just people getting it twice
supposedly the second case he gets
supposed to be mild
that's nice it's supposed to be a mild
case
and then mcdonald's who at mcdonald's
goes let's bring back the mcrib
during a pandemic like what sick
executive goes you know what
you know what this country needs how
many people died yesterday
you know what this country needs let's
bring back the mcrib
get up what the mcrib is because the
mcrib when i was a kid was legendary do
you mean what's actually in it or what
what it is it's it's it's a
a fake riblet pork patty drenched in
barbecue sauce i mean the original mcrib
was iconic but i don't know if they're
doing the original mcrib
let's read the wiki let's go over there
to the right oh
to the right here yeah to the right the
mcrib is a barbecue flavored pork
sandwich
periodically sold by the international
fast food restaurant chain mcdonald's
you could just say mcdonald's
it was first introduced in 1981. wow
four years before i was born after poor
sales it was removed in 1985 the year i
was born
ingredients mcrib pork patty home style
roll
mcrib sauce pickled slices slivered
onions
22 grams of fat 240 calories of energy
from fat
okay that's good so you're able to to
turn the key to start your car
and then uh 500 calories it doesn't seem
that bad ben
is it that unhealthy i don't think 500
calories is that it
sounds fine yeah yeah maybe i was hasty
in judging the good people at uh
mcdonald's
but we're gonna go get one after the
show just to try it out
just to see what's going on with it
see how many people are out during the
lockdown
imagine the cops knocking on our door
like where are you what are you doing
we're going to get the mcrib let them go
are they arresting people supposedly
they're arresting people now for
knowingly spreading covet
if you knowingly spread covet you are
going to be arrested
are there covered bug chasers like you
know there's bug chasers where people
want to get hiv
are there people that just want
coronavirus they're like i need it
i need to get covered just going to
walmart walking there are bug chasers
people that want to get hiv and you've
watched documentaries about this why do
they want to do it
i mean it's clearly like a
self-destructive thing right so they
they they i think it's truckers mostly
truckers
is like yeah want to get hiv i think so
i mean
truckers they don't have enough problems
self-driving cars elon musk
they just want to get aids that's how
bad it is the truckers want to get aids
because job security in this country is
so is that really who it is truckers i
imagine it's like glory hole guys at
truck stop bathrooms you know they they
pick up prostitutes and stuff
on the road it gets lonely some of those
men's imagination is so
dark and troubling even to me
that asking him to even just a simple
question
uh he goes down a a very dreary
and disturbing and he's creating this
reality where he's just lonely truckers
on the road
at glory halls that just want and now
why do they want
aids i don't understand i get lonely i
get trucker i get glory hole
i don't get aids i guess you just want
to die right it's like this sick like
i'm a
like people were like i'm a piss pig
like piss all over me and [ __ ] all over
me like yeah give me
give me all your diseases that you have
i'm a piece of [ __ ]
you know who's that are those the
truckers as well they're getting pissed
[ __ ] on some of them are pissed pigs and
you know now what is a piss pig
someone who wants you to piss on them
piss in their mouth they want to drink
piss you know they want to feel really i
feel like my attitude about
drinking piss has always been
is situational where it's like i feel
like if it's
appropriate to do it the time you might
want to taste a little bit but then
probably
spit it out you're open to it
interesting well i don't want
if someone is hot enough if someone is
good looking enough they can get you to
do whatever they want
if someone is good-looking enough they
could get me to
go to the a holiday with my family
that's true
you know what so i think that if
somebody's really good looking says
piss in my i will get a piss in your
mouth you have to say okay
no [ __ ] is a different story
yes a really good looking person says i
want to [ __ ] on you
that is probably disturbing
because then you tell all your friends
like oh i [ __ ] this person they're
really hot and then they go wow yeah
how was it you go well
i got [ __ ] on and then it ruins the
story i would imagine right
it ruins the story or people are people
are more intrigued
it's odd how sexuality develops like
it's very strange
like i always thought i might not be gay
if women were more intelligent
is that true i always believe that
so if women had a little bit more up
here i would probably [ __ ] them
that's a joke we have many female fans
and that's an
ironic joke because people expect my
audience to be full of misogynist and
it's not
it's full of sensitive crying men and
and
lovely women and that's what we we have
more women all the time
all the time all the time they're
rolling in here these ladies
the couples watch together the couples
watch together
isn't that nice and as soon as
quarantine ends we know what happens to
those relationships
maybe not are you afraid of your wife
leaving you after quarantine
no we're both working as normal so kind
of unaffected
well i i don't know maybe me and whitney
cummings will no longer be
married after quarantine that she's
through a friend's giving
what a horror you know and i respect her
but she threw a horrible event at her
home
and i was doing a friend's giving so
whitney then decided to do a
friendsgiving an
hour after me uh that's nice dan
carney's in uh the hospital he just
transitioned
no he uh he had a minor hip surgery
he'll be fine
um what is that on your instagram yeah
yeah i'm going to yours yeah you find
that picture of whitney's uh decor
it was it was grotesque so she has all
these influencers over
her house and i you know some of them
are nice olivia munn whatever and you
got amanda cerny i don't know who she is
and i don't care
uh and then you have the kesha's and all
these people
look how much autumn is at that table it
was grotesque it's
i l whitney is very successful but this
is target
this is walmart [ __ ] yeah which is fine
if you are at that place in your life
look how orange it is it's too much it's
too drenched in it that's a plastic fork
too
it's a plastic fork whitney also is too
much of a dude to give a dinner party
the great socialites the great women of
our time
rich women who know how to give a party
there's a there's a vibe
to be created whitney's a guy she's a
dude she's a successful dude
there's one black guy at the table and
she starts haranguing him about where he
pays taxes
it was the most uncomfortable thing
anyone had ever seen
she goes why do you pay taxes i go you
can't ask that
we're eating vegan stuffing that tastes
like a shoe
and she's yelling at a black about his
taxes and she doesn't mean it
but she's trying to have a conversation
about the state taxes but it just looks
bad
if you have one black guy there and you
go what are your financials
what's your credit score it was very
strange
now i had to cancel i canceled my
friendsgiving because we were going to
do it
i would have a lot of people and then
the whole thing just became insane and
it's like you know what
it's too much of a problem now you have
50 people in masks
who wants that right somebody test
positive i got to make call 50 people
the next day and go
hey thanks for coming by the way see a
doctor and i was gonna do a theme like a
you know like a tuscan winter wonderland
because i'm a classy [ __ ]
tuscan winter wonderland italian food
which is tough to
pull off she went full autumn
gross i mean the color of the bowls
i mean just grotesque and i love whitney
and it's great and i appreciate
everything she's done for me she's given
me uh
a lot of furniture for my home which i
paid her for
but that's still nice because it's it's
less than it would have cost me to
purchase by a lot
said i appreciate her and her friendship
but this
is not how to give an event it's not how
to do a party
it really wasn't it was very odd but i
felt like it was very rushed it was
something i was going to do and then she
was like oh i want to do it now too
and the chef was okay the chef was hot
the chef like has like saddle leather
boots on and like long hair and it's
like oh enough
a chef should look like raymond cump and
by the way
these shirts that we have on i am a wine
princess [ __ ] our new ray comp
model it i am a wine princess [ __ ]
this is ray cup merch get the link up
where you can get these uh
raycon was arrested outside of miley
cyrus's house in tennessee
all of these shirts go to his legal
defense fund it's very important
that rey uh have an adequate defense
against uh cyrus and her lying family by
the way
noah cyrus her her sister
called candace owens a nappy-headed hoe
right saw that on our story
not cool noah
there it is this is a picture of a wine
bottle holding a machete
ray is an artist i mean this is art he
drew this right he drew this
and this is i'm a wine princess [ __ ]
shirt
that you can get at the raycomp store
bonfire.com
store comp
right yeah yeah bonfire.com
it's on his twitter yeah it's on his
twitter and um
and it's a great shirt it's great for
the holidays it's great to just give the
family
you know i don't know but it is
phenomenal
but i i'm disappointed now that we're in
a lockdown again we can't have the party
it was gonna be a fun party
you know we talked about it many times
on the show we can't do it we just have
to
we have to do it uh you know another
time now
which is sad you know but
what are you gonna do but whitney filled
in with you know
orange play i mean what in
i mean it looked like uh like uh like a
high school like a party
like that you have like a high school
theater kid party
yeah like a church potluck almost yeah
meghan and i and i and i and i and i
respect the effort and she
she's a good person and she works hard
but giving a part there's an
art to entertaining and and giving an
actual
party and it was a tremendous
uh and despicable uh display a
failure of epic proportions uh
a strange vibe an odd configuration of
people uh very sad people
wealthy and yet sad uh a a
an interesting you know one woman whose
laugh was so
absurd that it was just derailing the
whole thing one woman was like
you know i just we irish goodbye we just
laughed i looked at jim jeffries i said
i gotta get out of here oh yeah me too
i think i'm gonna irish goodbye too he's
a happy guy huh
anyway i love him very funny he is very
he's a genius but you know but he's you
know he's he's more muted in person you
know
nobody's any fun in l.a that's the
problem nobody's fine we had these two
19 year old tick tock kids come here
sweet kids but i mean i mean can you
tell anyone apart from anyone else here
everybody's just like i'm on twitch i'm
a gamer nobody has any anecdotes
nobody has a fun anecdote
nobody turns around in this town and
goes my mother died during childbirth
i never knew her nobody has a fun
anecdote
my father was a drunk and tried to
molest me and the only way i got out of
it was by pushing him down the stairs
and paralyzing him oh no one says that
everyone goes i'm on twitch
that's all anyone says i stream on
twitch
i was beaten up every day and then i
became strong and and
and and and raped every nerd that beat
me up i realized i was gay but also a
fighter and wants a [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
heart no one has stories like that
everybody just goes i just sit in my
room and i just look at a
screen and then the people on the other
side look at me and we are
now we are going to do twitch and i
don't want you coming to me now and
saying hey
you [ __ ] all over this and then you do
it that's what it is here okay
the game is to be played so i'm going to
get on twitch and i don't need people
calling me a hypocrite okay don't call
me a hypocrite
don't get mad at me because uh candace
owens came on here
and and uh threw some shade at
what am i supposed to do i pushed back
she says this thing i don't agree
maybe yeah i don't know about that they
wanted me to yell at her
rogan they had that viral moment where
he's like why don't you believe
scientists and she just said i don't
i don't like science and he's just like
well why she's like i don't
who cares what did that do for any of
you you morons
the duke for anyone she's more popular
now than she was then you think that
worked
oh yeah she was dethroned after that huh
does it work
does it work idiots
i'm telling you the only thing that
works
apparently is heroin
it's the only thing that does its job in
this country because everybody who's on
it is like hey
my cousin keeps going back to it yeah
she said to me once she looked right on
my face and goes i love
heroin yeah she goes i love our family
and you but i love heroin it was like
what do you tell someone like that to do
like
but have you ever watched bravo like
she's she's found her thing
she's she's in she's in the
in the cut she's focused you know
do you want to be more productive in the
new year
yes do you want to start a an e-commerce
business and get uh take advantage of
the online digital marketplace
absolutely how are you gonna do it hmm
i don't know do you have a service that
i could use
shut up you haven't you haven't thought
about that
no i haven't i want to do it but i don't
do what what do you even want to do
i don't know i want to start an
e-commerce business with doing what
i don't know it's so overwhelming like i
have to ship things what are you
shipping you don't even have a business
yet
what are you trying to do i don't know i
just thought i could have a business
what kind of business um embroidered
golf balls with people's names on them
like for
christmas like you could how do you
embroider a golf ball
uh well i would use like you know
sharpies like
you know isn't that more engraved than
embroidered i guess engraved so
you want to engrave golf balls yeah yeah
what are the margins
because in order for me to even tell you
about this product
i have to be confident in the rest of
your business plan and it doesn't seem
like you have one
folks if you have a plan that is
actually a plan and not what this idiot
said
go to ship station ship station figures
out how to ship it all
they organize everything keep track of
all your orders make sure they're
they're getting shipped
in a cost-effective manner it's so
important
okay import orders from any sales
channel ship
with any carrier using our deeply
discounted rates automate just about any
shipping task
with ship station you'll spend a lot
less time on shipping and a lot more
time on growing your business
unlike ben it's no wonder ship station
has five-star more five-star reviews
than any shipping software
there's a good reason shipstation is the
number one choice for online sellers
okay ship more in less time
with some of the best rates available
anywhere they work with all the major
carriers us
postal service fedex ups so you can
compare
and choose the best shipping solution
for you and your own customer
get 2021 off to a great start by
visiting shipstation.com just go to my
just offer my code tim dillon gets 60
day free trial that's two months free no
hassle
stress free shipping go to
shipstation.com click on the microphone
at the top of the page and type in tim
dillon t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n
that ship station enter offer code tim
dillon ship station makeshift happen
if you want to shave your balls and [ __ ]
use manscaped it's important
it's great there's only one other
product on the market really the norelco
bodygroom
uh the manscape is better it is
performance packages the ultimate men's
hygiene bundle they've got it all in
here
they have a razor and all kinds of
powders and potions to make
yourself smell nice but i'll tell you
this it is good you don't have to worry
about nicking
your sensitive or private areas you are
really in control
the lawnmower 3.0 trimmer is the best
trimmer on the market for your balls
butt and body let's not forget
all of the other things that you get the
crop preserver ball deodorant crop
reviver get the performance package now
to receive
two free gifts the manscape boxers in
the shed travel bag which is lovely
also you will receive a replaceable
blade every three months to keep your
weed whacking and lawn mowing
time clean and enjoyable okay
performance package is the best value
manscape has to offer get 20
off plus free shipping with the code
timd manscape.com do it
great way to support the show great
little gift tim d
at manscape.com you get 20
off thank you manscape for making our
holes look sexy
we're playing around with some new ideas
here about some new spin-off side shows
that we may do
in relation to the podcast we don't know
we don't know we don't know but we're
we're talking to some interesting people
and coming up with some interesting new
ideas about having the most fun while
we're in la because while we're in la
however long that may be
we gotta make the most of it we gotta
have fun right this is gonna feel like
the christmas i spent
at least's lounge alone
it you know and i remember that
clear as day it was christmas eve i did
not go with my family i went alone to a
bar
in long island called lisa's lounge
and that people were doing cocaine on
the bar and drinking and then the owner
came out and he said to me he goes this
is what this place has always been about
he took a key bump and he goes i've
always wanted people to have a place
to go when they didn't have anywhere to
go for the holidays
that's why he opened the bar and i said
well that's good
i said thank you so much he's dead now
but
i said thank you so much and i sat there
and i got drunk and i was drinking with
these two people a guy who inherited a
lot of money
and then a hooker started um
taking his money and and and and then he
lost all of the inheritance
and ended up living back in his car the
guy got like a get out of jail free card
got 120 grand
a woman swooped in
fleeced him and he ended up living right
back in the car and he would
outside of the bar every night he would
just sleep in his car it wasn't even a
big car it's like a small pickup
and he would just knock back and then
the bartenders in the morning would
knock on his window and it's like hey
what's up buddy and he'd
shake off the sleep go right back in and
have a cocktail
and those are the types of people i miss
living in la i don't find any of them
because they had great
stories and they you know these are
people with a lot to do and i spent
a christmas eve with him and with the
woman who took all his money who he then
started talking to again like
he was mad at her and then he was like
well i lost all the money anyway
why keep this beef up right i'm not
gonna kill her
and so they hung out and we were all
hanging out we're just having a good
time and i remember that that was one of
the lowest
points of my life a truly truly low
point
of my life like one of the worst
times that i can remember where i truly
didn't want to be on earth
anymore and i can't even describe to you
how much worse whitney's friendsgiving
was
like how much worse it was than that
moment of my life it would be i couldn't
even describe
i couldn't even put together a metric to
make you understand
what a troubling experience it was how
were holiday retail numbers you know the
guys at cnbc
as everything's going to get so bad
they're going to just be cramming out a
roll on their face they're going to look
at each other like
how are holiday re and they're gonna
have to stare at each other like how are
the holiday numbers
maria what are the holiday retail
numbers right now
uh what is this is this recent
yeah these are people that are lying
yeah they think there's gonna be strong
finish to 2020 in spite of the pandemic
yeah i think not
i don't know well we're entering a place
now we're entering a time now where
the disparity between people that are
[ __ ] and people who aren't [ __ ]
is so the chasm is so great
which is why everyone yells at me oh
it's a conservative
nazi no i think there's a huge
problem with the level of inequality in
this country it's unsustainable
i've said it many times but now we're at
a point now where it's
we it's so we view
the random charity of influencers as
some
as like oh like when they print that
article about the kid that gives the
blankets
what are people supposed to go there
like what is the reaction supposed to be
everybody's supposed to go
well that well that's good what a nice
young man there are still good people in
the world
like we've gotten so bad now where
those types of stories are that's like
feel good news that's
feel good news that things are so bad
now
that the homelessness crisis is so crazy
if
10 of them get a snuggie it's a news
story
because people are like wow we need
something to just
[ __ ] pep everyone up because
everything's corona and death and
everyone's dead and no one can talk to
their family and
everyone's dying alone in bubbles in
hospitals
and nurses can't handle anything and
everybody's everything's [ __ ] at 700
000 people a month or filing for
unemployment
trump's not leaving and he's going but
he's not and he's still tweeting and
biden has no clue
and things are bad and they're gonna get
worse and the third wave i saw an
article the other day about the third
wave
get ready for the third wave but in
between that
in between your anxiety your your
[ __ ] heart palpitations from your
coffee
and the ssris you take just to get out
of bed please enjoy this very
heartwarming christmas story
about an influencer handing a blanket to
one of the now 90 trillion homeless
people
that live under bridges that used to
work in restaurants
unfortunately they never worked at gavin
newsom's winery because then they'd
still have their jobs
and can someone burn down his winery
metaphorically
as a bit in an article burn it down in
an
article do you see what i'm saying here
not
physically that's illegal burn it down
with satire
burn it down with satire mr
newsome he is good-looking people
like him who don't give a [ __ ] they
should not be allowed
to run a state they should not be
allowed to run the state of california
just kind of that pretty boy i own a
vineyard
i have multi look at what he owns go get
what gavin newsom owns
he owns everything he owns vineyards and
wineries
he founded the plump jack winery
napa yeah up in napa
huh
when's he up when's he out of here i
want to get logan paul in there as
governor
gotta get this guy out these people are
are are
establishing rules for lockdowns and
then they're breaking the lockdown
he had dinner at the french laundry
another mayor did something all of these
mayors are breaking their own lockdowns
they traveled the guy in denver traveled
the main goes well i gotta try i gotta
see my family
the austin mayor too yeah they're all
breaking their life if you break a
lockdown and i said this on twitter i
got 40 000 likes
if you break a lockdown and you're an
elected official you should be
fired you should resign you should be
forced to resign your party should
abandon you
he had businesses in san francisco like
in the mid 2000s like
he was a businessman here's my thing
with gavin newsom i just think what he's
doing
the the homelessness in california
problems in california
are so great and there's absolutely no
plan
coming from anybody that makes anyone
feel comfortable about opening a
business here
buying a home here um
i tell ben all the time i'm like we're
here
for a period of time i don't know when
that ends i do not know when that ends
you know musk just came out and said
he's not leaving california
so that was old news and now the rumor
is he is leaving
he's gonna go dude we thought we saw
those starlight satellites last night i
thought it was ufos
i thought it was ufos and it's actually
elon musk's starlight satellites
which are what what's he doing up there
no idea it looked like drone formations
you know
we really are at a point where the
technology is so amazing and yet it
doesn't make anyone's life better
which we kind of knew ted kaczynski knew
that
and i'm not saying you understand what
i'm saying
i'm not saying that ted kaczynski was
right i'm saying that he had
elements of truth in what he said just
like candace owens
had elements of truth everybody has
elements of truth
in a larger narrative what a tell we
weave
you know like candace owens talked about
her her cousin in the projects
what was her cousin's name mia i think
so i wonder if she really has a cousin
in the projects or she just made that up
she's like my cousin the project's me it
doesn't know who trump is i'm like wait
what
that was like the most racist thing she
said and my cousin me and the projects
didn't know what brexit was she didn't
even know what great britain is she's
like what the [ __ ] great britain
i'm like is that really what was
happening she was like my cousin mia
doesn't even know trump she'd be like
who trump
oh trump i'm like no one is that stupid
right do you really have a cousin in the
project or you have
invented some ratchet cousin
to tell people about
my cousin mia is pregnant with
non-babies
she don't know who trump is is that
really what's going on or
have you just invented that character to
just
make people more racist it's like a
character to pull out
where she's like listen you want to
really hate black people
my cousin mia doesn't know what a fork
is
she doesn't know she smokes all her food
she smokes her food she rolled a
sandwich in a blunt i saw it
i love it and then she goes i love me i
love my cousin mia
yeah she's my cousin mia i love her
but she's the ignorant stupid
welfare taking and you're like whoa hold
on
like when i watch the interview back i'm
like the thing i should have pushed back
on
is the description of her cousin who
lives in the project
like that was maybe the worst thing ever
that i didn't you know
my cousin mia man she just lived in the
projects and you know
every time i go there i just do the
alphabet with her one time just to show
her
show her what it is i'm like wait what
hold on you seem like you're being a nut
but what are you gonna do next week we
will have diamond and silk
on we have a christmas special diamond
and silk the reverend jesse lee peterson
tesla ceo elon musk has told friends and
associates he plans to move to texas
that's the rumor today that's what
people are saying
good for him you know i liked him and
then he named the baby that crazy name
i i was i was done after i know rogan
loves him i was done after that
i was done after he named the baby the
math equation
the baby name i i was cut it done i was
just kind of like okay man i get it
yeah xaea2 yeah i just
i don't know i i after that i said
let's just let's just move on yeah you
know
i can't i can't be involved but
i wish everyone the best for the
lockdown in the holiday season i hope
that you are
enjoying yourselves and finding uh you
know i'm gonna get a christmas tree this
year i haven't had a tree in a long time
you should get one i'm gonna get a
christmas tree
should i we do a i think i should get a
christmas tree and put masks on it i
call it a cova tree yeah yeah
little tests hang tests little tests and
masks
a cover tree that might be fun
a coveted tree i mean i do want to get a
christmas tree i want to enjoy the
holiday as much as i can
you know as someone without a family and
many friends and who's
disgusted by most of what he sees and
hears and feels
i do want to still enjoy the holiday
season you know
in a rapidly decaying oligarchy
that's so it's barely funny anymore like
that's how
that's how bad things have gotten
they're they're not even funny
not even because they're too tragic
they've always been that
they're not funny anymore because
there's a remarkable
sameness to everything like we feel like
we're in round two of something
it's like we're and we're going again
we're
going again get ready
you know i'm just kind of like when the
[ __ ] are we going to break out
and i wonder what post-quarantine is
going to look like are people going to
say [ __ ] technology
are they just going to say i want to
connect with real people again i want to
connect with human beings again
we've lived our lives on these screens
we've sacrificed
everything for in the service of
algorithms
is that gonna be the vibe are people
gonna say [ __ ] it
throw away the tv i mean throw it in
macbooks and if any iphones
we're gonna run out let's go hiking
again let's go swimming
let's go do what we want to do let's do
music festivals let's do live comedy
let's do live theater let's get out
there let's reconnect with people let's
is that what's gonna happen is that
what's gonna even as i say it i know the
answer is no
even as i say it now but i mean that
would be like a resurgence of light like
you finally go back outside and go
man i missed life i miss going to a
diner with someone in lunch with a
friend who i don't even like
but i miss that i miss the feeling of
going out to a crowded bar i miss being
on a crowded
subway i miss being on a plane where
people are coughing and sneezing and i
didn't think i was going to die
when i left i mean when's that going to
come back i miss the feeling of being in
an
office and opening the refrigerator and
seeing who brought what lunch and what i
could technically steal
i miss shitty office christmas parties i
miss
you know going out and seeing people
that you you you hate far
less than you should aren't those nice
people that you hate
far less than you should i should hate
this person a lot more
based on everything about them and yet
i still have some
level of it's like fine
fine that was a lot of my friends
throughout my entire life you'd go
okay fine
you're here and and i miss that
i miss the tacit agreements we make the
the small just like everything now is
too intense
there's no casual anything anymore
everything you got to be
in every friendship's like your best
friend every person that you talk to
is like super close i miss casual
friendships i miss acquaintances i miss
[ __ ] they didn't matter
i miss talking to someone and then watch
them hit by a bus and go
and walking away i miss so much of life
needs to go back to the casual yeah
where it doesn't matter the breeze that
blows
the freedom to not care now
everything is so intense cause you could
die i guess
so you every [ __ ] every friendship
every business deal everything is super
uber intense everything's a decision to
go to the store
weigh the risk what am i doing have
these people over are they clean
have they been careful who have they
been seeing
everything is too intense you can't
casually hate people
in your vicinity anymore yeah you can't
just
casually invite people over and when
they leave look at your friend and go
you know they're not that smart they
think they're smart
they're not you can't do it anymore
because everything feels so intense
and i think that that's sad we need to
introduce the casual
back to life we don't have the casual
now
everything is a big [ __ ] production
everything is super intense and very
involved everything you want to do is
involved
and every friendship you have now is
like
trauma bonding and that's good
for certain instances but i think a lot
of people we got to go back now
obviously you can have a
tight-knit group of close friends but we
gotta go back to
the casual where people because this is
not life
this unending drumbeat of hell and
horror is not
life we have to go back to something
that
feels more like who care no one has said
who cares
and meant it in years and that's a big
problem
because that means everybody cares and
that's a huge issue
the last thing you want people to do is
care because they [ __ ] it up
they [ __ ] it up you ever have somebody
get really excited about all the things
they want to help you with and then you
go
back off back off
nobody said who cares you got to say who
cares you got to say to yourself
like yeah man uh yeah have them over or
don't
we'll go to that thing or we won't right
who cares
what does it matter what does any of it
matter now everything
matters and and and it's just
unfortunate and that's what i want i
want the return of the casual
so that's what i hope when this is over
i'm just gonna travel
and walk around and go hey i don't care
yeah i don't care
and that's gonna feel so good to not
care
about anything or anyone
do you get it that's what we're trying
to get back here
total and utter [ __ ]
what is the word i'm looking for i
listen or no when you don't care it's
with an a
apathy apathy
let's get back to that you see a nurse
you go [ __ ] her
you don't feel bad for her yeah yeah
[ __ ]
who i don't know that [ __ ] can't we get
back to that
you look at politicians you go [ __ ] oh
yeah they're lying this scum get them
away
you go own your winery jerk off wine but
i don't care
because nothing is a life or death
deal but things are too serious right
now
and we can't go back we need to be able
to go back
to that take oh the schools are open the
schools are called
[ __ ] them we need to go back to that
i'm thinking about things i've never
even thought about like are the kids
safe in the school
it's not my business
i just want to go back to that we all
must go back to that
it's the american way truly
it's the american way to go back to a
casual casual
nonchalant things i care about people
now so much
for no reason really truly i look at
people and i go
i care about them and i want them
to be okay and that's
destroying me
you know worrying about other people
is absolutely undoing me it's
destroying me i need to go back
to a thing where i don't worry
about anyone even myself
i just need to go back to that we need
to go back to that as a now a lot of
people are like oh this is not
true and this is making me think about a
lot of interesting things
that's what i try to do on the show but
they're like this is like this time has
actually been a blessing no it hasn't
it's been a journey
no it hasn't it's been really good for
me and it's really showed me who my
close friends were
no it hasn't you're trauma bonding
you're in a dugout you're in a foxhole
you still you're in a war
people are shooting at you yeah are you
close with the person next to you i bet
you are
no your friends are your friends when
things are going well
now when things are when things are
going horrible this is
not another thing i want to clear up by
the way okay because this is the other
thing that people don't understand they
go
your friends are only your friends in
the [ __ ] when things are in the [ __ ]
that's not true
tons of people love to be around [ __ ]
and misery and will find you
your friends are actually your friends
when things are going well they're not
jealous of you
they're not they you know threaten them
you have a good life and they're happy
for you and that's a real friendship
when you are in the worst time ever
actually many people come out and
they're like
i'm here for you but what they really
want to do is just watch you
911 style jump out of the south tower
window
and fall to the ground because that's
what people like to do they like to
watch
each other emolliate so don't put too
much stock into anything
when things are good that's when you
figure out who your friends are and
things have been good for me
right now i mean things are good for us
right now even though things are bad in
the world
the show has been good and the live
dates have gone good and i have some
friends i have a handful of friends and
i have a lot of acquaintances
but i have a small i have less than 10
really close friends far
less than 10. i don't want to i don't
want to say how many i really have
because then i have 10 people are like
well i thought
it's all problem but it's a small group
of people that i'm friends with now and
and
when i when i was doing horribly i had
a hundred friends like when i look at
the text i got when things were going
really really like when i was just an
open micro in new york city and
nobody cared i had no career everyone's
like hey i'd be thanksgiving man
they would all take photos of our
families through these [ __ ] they don't
understand
us we're the next generation [ __ ] these
[ __ ]
go in there steal a little money out of
the purse
and that then everybody's uh they're all
out for they're all in in
but then when things go go decently you
truly see there's a few people that
actually come out to be a friend that is
the opposite of what you're told
you're told that your real friends are
around you during the hard times
untrue untrue your
real friends are around during the good
times
that's the reality many of you
don't want to hear that but
that's the reality it's the good times
go give blankets to people that don't
need them
you understand impress me
you want to impress me do you want to
really impress me tic toc stars
go take those blankets
and give them back to ellen
knock on the door hi
give them back to her go you deserve
these you crazy [ __ ]
that would impress me because that would
mean they got because a blanket for a
homeless person
is nice it's a nice thing
but i would be much more interested if
that homeless person was a
sociopathic millionaire talk show host
then they get the blanket
then you see and why why tim
you don't understand you're sitting in
the back and go well i know that there's
a point here
because there's no story if you give
ellen the blanket
so it's real
you see if you give the millionaire the
blanket
it's real because no one
reports or thinks favorably of you
for doing it
you get it now or you still confused
dummies
give charity to the rich
yes or yes
do you want to prove do you want to
prove
that you have the christmas spirit give
to those that have
give to those that have
because it's real because it's real
there's no ulterior motive
give to those that have more than you
giving to those that have less than you
shows me that you want me to come up and
pat you
on the back for the things that you are
doing for those that have less than you
it's not right give to those that have
more
yeah if you see someone that's doing
well
help them do better that's
that's the real less the christmas carol
was great up until the end
when scrooge became a loser because what
scrooge was saying is
we have to work oh but mister i want to
go have
i want to go to the have the holidays
with my family
and screwed scrooge
gave him a job right scrooge gave bob
cratchit a job
is it scrooge's fault that he had a
[ __ ]
no scrooge goes hey come
to work and be a clerk even knows who
that is right with a quill pen
be a freak in that corner and i'll
[ __ ]
be a miser and run this ship
and then what did bob crouch you do i
forget
he goes i want to go home with my family
because it's christmas
and scrooge goes you better [ __ ] you
better figure it out
you better get this [ __ ] done and
and uh and i i don't remember i think
cratchit leaves cratchit leaves and goes
home to be with his loser
family is his son like
like his crippled son and his
disgusting wife and in this hovel that
he lives in
and then he's there and then scrooge a
[ __ ] king
gets harassed by these
communist ghosts
aoc
bernie sanders and uh
i don't even know elon omar maybe yeah
ilhan omar
i was gonna say cornell west because he
kind of has a ghost look
and then he wakes up the next day and he
goes buy the fattest turkey and give it
to
this loser cratchit
it's not real do you understand that
they had to scare him
they had to send the ghost scrooge knew
he was right live
in the security that you are correct all
the time
even when you're not right be right
and scrooge by telling crash you have to
work you can things don't just happen
you have to work is the best lesson of
that does it matter about the [ __ ] i
want to eat figgy pudding
yes yes yes but you must you must work
and that was the real lesson of the
christmas carol when he wakes up the
next day and he goes
here's the turkey and bring the turkey
to the family also like can you imagine
like that wouldn't even work like like
like he would send a turkey and like the
wife would be like this
[ __ ] guy who tortures you every day
sending the turkey over now like
what's his game what's this guy's game
this whole misers piece of [ __ ] you know
so that's how ben's wife feels about me
like what i could i could do
i could deliver a uh rolls royce to the
house for both of them
she'd go what is this do you have the
brakes in what do we just try to kill me
so that's my whole problem with the
christmas carol
is that it it's a it's a it's a it's an
assault on a
on a business owner right
scrooge and by the way am i
is the show sponsored by turning point
usa yes it is
and will i be doing a turning point
usa's re-reading of scrooge
yes i will and will i be doing it with
charlie kirk while i just may
and me and charlie clark will re-read a
new version of scrooge where there is
respect
for the entrepreneur
okay and not some low-level
vagabond clerk and his [ __ ]
son we're doing a new version of the
christmas account with respect for the
entrepreneur
we're doing a new version of oliver
twist you know oliver twist what's the
famous line in oliver twist
can i have some more please sir may i
have some more
and the new line when me and charlie
rewritten it is sir
i've had more than enough and everyone
else has had too much and they're
getting lazy
so can i please go back to work that's
the new line
new readings of the turning point usa is
new readings of the classics with tim
dillon and charlie kirk i have not sold
out
i have bought in
[Laughter]
you see there's a difference between
selling out and buying in and i find
that
i just want a blanket i just hope
someone gives me a blanket
that's how you know you're doing bad so
the first reason
you know that you've had a bad week is
if people call you up and they're like
hey uh we just want you to be really
careful
because of coven and the second reason
you know you've had a bad week and you
look like [ __ ]
is if a tick tock star hands you a
blanket
then you know things are not going well
so if those two things are happening
you might wanna you might wanna change
what you're doing before you have to
great line for my old boss
change before you have to he's in jail
change
before you have to you see but what i
said about friendship there is so
so true so correct and many of you will
understand that
and many of you won't understand it
because you're trained in this basic
[ __ ] logic
of just swallowing these hallmark fairy
tales about what life is
and they're like when the going gets
tough
shut up it's not true
okay it's not true so to the rules today
are this
give to those that have more
because it makes you feel good and it's
real
okay that's the rule uh another rule is
your real friends are around
during times of jubilation not misery
it's very true you might you might not
like that
uh the third rule is only attend the
party whitney cummings house if you've
planned it
she is i mean god that was
what did you think what was your
impression of it well i'm always on the
hook for everything here because he
doesn't say anything
i mean the food was kind of like
inedible in my opinion yeah it was bad
what do you think about the uh what was
vegan and [ __ ] that's what they do in
l.a it's vegan yeah i just have to do
that
yeah it's a satanic priestess does it
blesses it what
what do you think about uh what did you
think about the decor what was the
overall vibe
it was it felt more halloween to me like
the
it did the cook had a big like hat yeah
and like
everything was orange it felt now you
were around for the planning of my event
which didn't happen but it was still
planned
correct i assisted it was just going to
be a different level
oh yeah it was just going to be a little
bit of a different level yeah yeah i
mean it's a different level
more attention to detail you know oh
yeah
oh yeah that's all and a funner crew
yeah you think
i mean she's got like it's like half
influencers half reality stars
people that she's dug out of a comedy
chat from 1992 haven't worked in 30
years i'm just like some influencers
like my titties
and then some comic next to them that
lives in a car it's like what is going
on
you know some instagram influencers like
look at my golden [ __ ] and then the
person next to them's like i live in a
rav4 i found
so there's no semblance i don't even
understand what's happening there
you know it's like when people with
drugs just hang out with people without
drugs it would be like yeah i don't
right yeah what are you doing here
very strange uh new studio being built
when do you think we'll have the new
studio
right like actually by the new year we
have to get some custom things built
it's going to take a couple weeks it's
going to take a couple of weeks
thank you for everybody who is supported
the fake business campaign
fake business will be doing real
business up until oh it's over now
well if you're on the west coast and
this episode's up you might have a
couple hours to stop by
yeah i mean if you haven't bought it by
now what are you really doing yeah
what are you really doing out there
you know so we're gonna leave now we're
gonna disobey the lockdown because this
is not essential
uh well get to mcrib we're podcasts so
we're media so i'm allowed to travel to
your house and back to mine
so we're allowed to go get food right
for because we have to come back and do
ads after we go get the mcrib
good point hey officer
we're a podcast have you heard of
podcasting
we're the media we are the media now
another thing i said is a joke
it's now somehow real it's true we're
the media
what a [ __ ] what an insane
realization huh
yeah we're allowed to leave our homes
because we're the media
yeah you think gavin newsom's in an
office one day going
you're letting these [ __ ] go to and
from each other's houses and you're
telling people to burn down my wineries
it's gavin it's a metaphor like a fan of
the shows and they're going kevin is uh
he said to it was satire yeah burned
down the winery with satter
you know um i'm not telling anyone
this is how i'll end the show which is
fun this is how we're gonna end the show
i am i just wanna clarify right now i am
not telling anyone to set gavin newsom's
winery on fire
that is not what i'm doing at all this
is a joke
i'm not
if you're in the area and you have a lit
cigarette
[Laughter]